Hey, Gene, maybe I need to be focusing my guys in on these contracts.
That's one area I might have gotten too smart.
I just went month to month.
And maybe they're dude, that's a hundred percent, bro.
It's not even about the like, I'm not saying that's a hundred percent,
but like, if you're not doing a contract, you're crazy.
That's like why it's part of the process.
It's not that if they sign a six month contract,
you're even going to take them to court.
Like, let's be real, the amount of money it's going to cost you to take them to court
and how much you're going to get, it's not really worth it.
The fact of the matter is when they know that there's a contract
and they physically or they intentionally sign it,
that is them committing.
And I always use this analogy.
Is it easier for someone to end a relationship
that is like a boyfriend, girlfriend relationship or a marriage?
You might have like some real shit going on in your marriage,
but because you've committed, because you've gone through that process,
you've signed that shit.
And because it's not as easy to get out of without having a little bit of like shit happen,
people think twice, man.
People think twice, three times, four times, sign that thing.
Even though you know damn well that like at the end of the day,
you're probably not going to get anything from them in court.
It's them signing, it's them committing.
And here's how I pitched the contract, Gene.
I say, look, yeah, of course there's a contract.
I'm committing to you.
I'm a hundred percent exclusive to you.
I can't talk to any other business owners.
If we don't do an agreement, then that's like me being committed to you,
but you can quit at any time.
I'm committing to you.
I'm ceasing all conversations with business owners.
I'm going all in on you.
That's like having a marriage where only one person's married,
the other person could do whatever the hell they want.
It doesn't make sense.
Yes, there's a contract.
It's six months.
At the end of six months, if you don't like me, I don't like you, we end that shit.
But my guess is that at the end of this thing,
you're just going to ask me if I can keep the price the same
and not increase the price because I'm going to be killing it for you.
That's how I pitch it.
Don't shy away from it.
Contract's not a big deal.
We sign contracts every day.
We get contracts on our phone.
We got contracts in our houses.
Most people have contracts on their cars.
People have contracts on everything.
We got all kinds of stuff.
Isaac, we just went to the gym.
We just signed a three-year contract in the gym.
Contracts are part of life.
Don't let people tell you, I don't do contracts.
Bullshit.
Ask them, did you pay for your phone outright?
I actually did.
Funny thing is I say that I actually bought the shit outright.
But 99% of people, they have contracts.
That's part of life.